i pledge allegiance  i pledge allegiance to the flag to the  flag of the united states of america  from the united states of america and to  the republic and  to the republic for which it stands it  stands  one nation one nation under god under  god  indivisible and indivisible with liberty  liberty  and justice for all  that's a pledge that was awesome  shout out to sergeant major brad casales  marine corps junior rotc  over at basic high down in henderson  thank you very much of course you can  send us a video as well  we're studying the pledge we'll share it  on the air email it to us or send it to  us on social media that was  stupendous